you know those visual effects started
somewhere many years ago the world was
stunned by the appearance of the
strongest scariest presence in Hollywood
but Joan Crawford would turn I'm sorry
no he would he would he would climb the
Empire State Building and capture the
heart of a beautiful woman while
swatting down planes with the flick of
his hairy hand was not Jack Palance it
was the greatest date of all King Kong
ladies and gentlemen the beauty who
charmed the Beast
the legendary Fay Wray
one
you can do this way for everybody
I'm Ralph Edwards and this is your life
goodie I'm so glad my life is with you
we got a scoop here it's great to have
you with us as all of these great stars
of the past 7 years of Oscar right now
I'm going to present these two guys they
came here as best friends they will
leave her his best friends and they
insist that they will always be best
friends wait till I find out that
there's only one Oscar statue if they
win for original screenplay yeah you
know ladies and gentlemen would you like
to introduce them Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck there you go hey ray